One of the most important kitchen tools
you're gonna need to cook from scratch.
Decent set of knives. Now
I had a really nice knife set
that my husband bought me when we first got married.
But it's definitely time for an upgrade.
I grab this beautiful knife block.
It has a sharpener
that's really important cause I always forget to sharpen my knives.
And it also has a pair of Scissors.
And I'm always running low on kitchen Scissors.
You can always tell when a knife is good.
As if the solid piece of metal goes all the way through the handle.
And these do. So there is solid knife.
They made easy work with slicing through this pineapple.
I actually met my husband in Hawaii
and we used to cut up so much pineapple when we first got married.
Used to live right next to the doll plantation.
So this giving great memories today.